c'était donc le troisième épisode d'une
série exclusive initié par notre chaîne
LCP et intitulée génération 2008 qui
seront-ils demain troisième épisode
d'une série ambitieuse puisque son
réalisateur François Chevret en temps
suivre les 5 jeunes que vous venez de
voir à l'instant chaque année pendant 10
ans histoire de mieux capter le parcours
d'une génération bienvenue dans des
badogs François Chevret vous êtes
journaliste réalisateur et c'est donc à
vous que notre chaîne a confié la
réalisation de ce formidable projet ce
projet vous l'avez entamé voilà donc
maintenant trois ans nos collégiens
faisaient alors leur entrée en 6e et
c'était en pleine crise du covid
d'ailleurs moment tout à fait
particulier pour ce premier épisode de
notre série et cette fois c'était donc
la rentrée en quatrième qui était au
menu de cette génération 2008 on va bien
sûr en reparler tout de suite ensemble
avec Thierry Vincent bienvenue à vous
nous vous avons vu dans ce
supplémentaires et pour cause vous êtes
professeur de technologie dans ce fameux
collège des gayeuls de Rennes et vous
étiez l'an dernier le professeur
principal de la classe que nous avons
suivie merci de votre présence
aujourd'hui sur ce plateau de débat doc
qui a elle MLM maggie est également avec
nous bienvenue vous êtes sociologue
chargé de recherche à l'Institut
national de la jeunesse et de
l'éducation populaire je vous remercie
vous aussi parce que vous étiez déjà là
l'an dernier à l'occasion de la rentrée
des mêmes enfants en 5ème et ça nous a
permis ça va nous permettre d'avoir un
suivi avec vous avec vos yeux votre
perception de ces cinq élèves que nous
avons donc suivi dans votre série
François Chevret la quatrième la
quatrième c'est souvent présenté c'est
vrai comme un tournant dans le cursus
scolaire déjà aujourd'hui vous l'avez
perdu ce tournant à travers le suivi de
ces cinq ado ce sont des adolescents
c'est comme ça qu'il faut les appeler
depuis maintenant trois ans oui bah déjà
physiquement on peut voir qu'ils ont
tous grandi Riwan c'est un peu devenu un
géant voilà ils ont tous grandi
et puis les thématiques ont changé à la
fois dans leur discussion on parle
d'autre chose on est un peu moins enfant
il y a aussi une perception de soi qui
s'est développée notamment chez les de
filles on peut le voir dans le
documentaire elles arrivent à parler
d'elle-même et à se voir et à réussir à
un peu à s'analiser et puis les sujets
en cours voilà on a des cours sont
toujours plus matures que les garçons
c'est ce que vous nous aviez dit l'année
dernière pour parler de ce qui était le
deuxième épisode de cette série en
l'occurrence je crois que ça se voit un
peu là voilà ce sont juste cinq jeunes
on va pas raconter l'histoire de toute
une jeunesse à travers cinq jeunes mais
oui clairement on sent que les mots
viennent plus facilement
on sent qu'elles sont capables de se
regarder de analyser ouais de parler
d'elle-même en fait c'est ça en fait
c'est de se poser des questions et que
peut-être que les garçons ne sont pas
encore là et c'est vrai qu'on l'a perçu
dans votre dans votre film on va voir un
premier extrait les questions de vous
Thierry Vincent et les questions Lilou
Lilou qui vous a confié dans un débat
que vous aviez organisé dans votre dans
votre classe pour
voilà pour la température de cette
classe pour juger de l'ambiance et les
loups avaient fait part de problèmes de
harcèlement vous l'avez prise à part on
l'a vu dans ce documentaire à la fin de
ce cours et puis ensuite vous avez
décidé d'appeler la mère de Lilou c'est
cet extrait nous allons passer
maintenant
oui bonjour Alors je tenais à vous
appeler parce que j'ai eu une petite
discussion avec Lilou aujourd'hui il y a
quelques camarades qui se moqueraient un
peu d'elle de temps en temps
[Musique]
je l'ai vraiment vu atteinte tout à
l'heure qu'elle a eu très vite les
larmes aux yeux
on est proche du harcèlement au bout
d'un moment
[Musique]
les loups qui dit souffrir d'une forme
de harcèlement vous attend donc sa mère
c'est l'extrême venant de voir on
connaît la fin malheureusement les loups
va quitter le collège pour rejoindre un
établissement privé qu'on ne sait pas
c'est la suite que vous avez donné à
cette entretien avec la mère de Lilou et
à cette demande peut-être cet appel ce
SOS peut-être de Lilou quelle est la
suite de cet entretien téléphonique avec
sa mère alors on a déjà je voudrais
remercier les camarades parce que Lilou
s'est confié sur son maître dans la
classe mais ce sont vraiment des
camarades qui sont venus me parler du
harcèlement dont elle était la cause
donc je voudrais aller remercier et les
encourager à continuer et donc voilà on
a eu la discussion avec Lilou elle
voulait elle absolument ne pas en parler
ne pas que je n'ai pas de discussion
avec les les auteurs du harcèlement
il a fallu que je discute beaucoup avec
elle on voit un cours extrême et ça a
duré un bon moment pour quelle motorise
aussi à appeler sa maman et voilà donc
elle m'a autorisé finalement à discuter
avec les camarades afin de leur que je
puisse leur faire prendre contre elle
aussi qu'elle était leur rôle dans dans
le mal-être de Lilou et de faire avancer
les choses comment on peut le décrire
cette cette forme de harcèlement dont
elle disait souffrir alors c'était des
moqueries des moqueries à répétition ce
qu'elle dit sur le physique sur sa façon
de s'habiller sur sa façon de dessiner
en cours d'arts plastiques
voilà globalement c'était beaucoup
démocris il y a eu un suivi tout au long
de l'année et comment les loups en est
arrivé à vouloir quitter cet
établissement à la fin de cette année de
Quatrième vous l'analysez comment alors
je vais pas Lilou l'analyse bien donc je
vais je fais la laisser avec son analyse
qui qui je trouve est bonne
je crois qu'elle a besoin de changer
d'air
moi et le collège on considère pas comme
un échec au contraire j'ai l'impression
que l'eau elle a énormément mûri entre
le moment où je l'ai vu dans cette
entretien et le moment où elle discute
en face à face avec François et et
on voit qu'elle a vraiment pris une
décision qu'il a libère donc est-ce que
c'était la première fois vous étiez
confronté à un cas dit de harcèlement
scolaire
est-ce que dans le corps enseignant
aujourd'hui dans cet établissement dans
ce collège des Gayeulles vous en
discutez et vous discutez de la manière
d'appréhender ce type de problème
remonté par des élèves alors le
harcèlement non c'était pas la première
fois malheureusement il y avait une un
précédent dans la même classe
mais qui avait été pris beaucoup plus
tôt qui avait été annoncé aussi repéré
par les mêmes camarades qui qui sont
venus m'alerter donc il y a pu être
traité d'une façon beaucoup plus rapide
voilà donc il y a eu moins de
conséquences au niveau des élèves de
l'élève qui était qui était ciblés
la prise en compte du harcèlement
scolaire c'est relativement récent il y
a une loi très récente qui en fait
d'ailleurs un délit date du 2 mars
dernier 2 mars
2022 c'est donc un délié à part entière
aujourd'hui on risque jusqu'à 10 ans de
prison si la victime a tenté de se
suicider ou ont été amené à passer à
l'acte qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire
aujourd'hui de cette prise en compte du
harcèlement scolaire dans des
établissements comme celui qu'on a vu le
collège des Gayeulles à Rennes ce qui
est intéressant dans ce qu'on voit dans
la manière dont Lilou va réussir à
s'exprimer devant toute la classe y
compris peut-être devant des élèves qui
vont participer à la situation de
harcèlement c'est qu'elle reconnaît
malgré tout l'institution scolaire comme
étant capable d'entendre son problème
elle va pas forcément parler de
harcèlement d'ailleurs elle va dire des
moqueries des insultes des réflexions
qui lui vont pas elle va parler de la
réputation qui pèse beaucoup sur des
filles beaucoup plus que sur les garçons
c'est pas les mêmes enjeux les enjeux
autour du corps de la mise en scène du
corps et tout ça mais par contre la
force qu'elle a de le dire devant tout
le monde devant une caméra devant un
moment qui est un peu particulier elle
va profiter finalement du documentaire
pour mettre les pieds dans le plat sur
quelque chose qui était latent qui
commençait on sent bien à être repéré
sur lequel elle commence à être déjà
ce qu'elle vous a confié c'était pas
nouveau dans son parcours mais elle se
saisit d'un moment au sein de l'école
pour parler de violence qu'elle subit à
l'école et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que du coup par là elle rejoint tout un
certain nombre d'élèves qui vont aussi
se sentir légitime à parler de situation
de violence dans l'école faites à
l'école ce qui est relativement nouveau
puisque jusqu'à finalement qu'on parle
vraiment de la question du harcèlement
la question des violences à l'école elle
était vraiment mise dans les familles à
côté oui mais c'est un problème mais on
va se débrouiller pour pas causer de
problèmes et d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'elle
dit je veux pas faire de problème
mais elle fait pas des problèmes à
dénoncer de la violence et c'est bien ça
la difficulté qu'il y a avec les
adolescentes et les adolescents c'est tu
es concerné par des actes de violence
c'est pas parce que tu les dénonces que
tu vas produire un problème le problème
il est de toute façon là donc maintenant
il va trouver va falloir trouver les
adultes du côté des profs du côté de tes
parents pour trouver une solution et je
trouve qu'elle a une force particulière
à ce moment-là alors le harcèlement
scolaire commence dès la primaire mais
c'est sans doute au collège les études
le coron en tout cas que que ce
phénomène est le plus fort le plus le
plus présent alors il y a même des
situations de harcèlement de tension de
violence dès la maternelle en fait mais
alors l'école primaire c'est un espace
social ou beaucoup de gens se
connaissent où il y a moins de brassage
du nombre d'élèves du nombre de familles
du enfin voilà il y a les enseignantes
sont présentes les enseignants sont
présents au quotidien avec les enfants
le collège c'est un moment on a plus de
temps ou vont arriver aussi des
téléphones portables et tout ça qui vont
participer à cloisonner plein d'espaces
de vie différents et donc ben
c'est aussi un moment on va plus avoir
des d'autres amis qu'on connaît moins
les parents se connaissent moins entre
eux s'il y a une tension à un problème
c'est moins facile de s'appeler pour
faire un peu de prévention pour border
un peu son ado et puis il y a beaucoup
de choses on met sur le dos c'est des
ados il ou elle est différent il va pas
bien c'est normal c'est l'adolescence et
c'est vrai que ça se fait phénomène
nouveau aussi concernant le harcèlement
scolaire c'est il se poursuit en dehors
de l'établissement scolaire et ça grâce
aux réseaux sociaux alors chez les
jeunes c'est souvent Instagram Tik Tok
aujourd'hui ça a été le cas pour les
loups concernant ce harcèlement dont
elle souffrait Lilou ne m'a pas parlé
d'un harcèlement dont elle serait
victime sur les réseaux sociaux par
contre elle en a vu c'est pour ça que
elle a une vraie capacité à avoir ce qui
se passe sur les réseaux sociaux parce
qu'elle voit des harcèlements elle voit
des moqueries elle trouve ça affreux et
en fait elle se retrouve des fois
installé une application à la supprimer
10 minutes après à la remettre parce
qu'elle a du mal à supporter les
moqueries qui peut y avoir et je vois ça
comme une zone de non-droit une zone
sans adulte ou finalement n'importe quel
enfant peut dire ce qu'il veut
d'insultant sans avoir de contrôle
derrière des parents et le chef de
l'État Emmanuel Macron estimait le
nombre d'enfants victimes de harcèlement
scolaire à environ un million
aujourd'hui en France à l'occasion de la
dernière rentrée scolaire et je l'ai dit
c'est un délire aujourd'hui c'est une
loi qui date du 2 mars dernier on va
voir un deuxième extrait et cette fois
il est question de politique c'est vrai
que vous tourniez ce film dans les
conditions particulières c'était l'année
d'une élection présidentielle et des
élections législatives voilà ce que vous
avez le petit quiz que vous avez donné
aux enfants dans votre documentaire
François Chevret
Emmanuel Macron alors aujourd'hui je
crois c'est droite non si je me trompe
j'ai pas envie de me tromper c'est
cendres non peut-être un peu sur la
droite une droite
c'est droite non c'est golf c'est les
deux centre c'est un centre
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est à gauche lui on
l'attend pour partout
cette élection présidentielle est-ce
qu'ils en ont beaucoup parlé
est-ce que ça les intéressait la
politique
je trouve que bon ils connaissent pas
trop mal mon ami un peu le côté marrant
mais ça peut quand même des choses à
dire dessus ils s'y sont intéressés de
toute façon relative on va dire
voilà bon on voit que voilà gauche
droite c'est pas forcément très clair
tout le four est-ce qu'ils ont regretté
de ne pas pouvoir voter par exemple non
alors justement c'est une question je
leur ai posé la question je leur ai
demandé s'il pensait pas que les adultes
décident pour eux
ils se disent que non parce que ils sont
un peu jeunes ils ont un peu 13,14 ans
donc c'est peut-être pas le moment on se
pose ce genre de question ils auront
bien le temps et puis voilà ils
aimeraient voter en conscience donc il
faudrait s'y intéresser davantage et
mettre un bulletin comme ça gratuitement
dans un dans une urne donc non pour le
moment ils sont pas encore là-dedans
vous avez ressenti la même chose auprès
de cette classe en tant que professeur
principal peu d'appétence finalement
pour la vie politique et pourtant
l'actualité était assez riche alors
c'est ils aiment bien en parler mais
effectivement alors moi c'est dans mon
cours c'est plus compliqué mais on
arrive toujours à avoir des débats quand
même bien sûr mais c'est toujours eu
d'un point de vue voilà voilà ce qu'on
ce dont on entend parler
puisque vraiment j'ai des décisions
après il réfléchissent ils entendent des
choses ils sont capables d'en reparler
et puis de d'avoir bien compris on le
voit dans le doc de toute façon ils ont
quand même des bonnes analyses
sur ce qu'ils entendent autour alors il
existe bien sûr les cours d'éducation
morale et civiques alors ça c'est
valable je crois dès l'école primaire
jusqu'au lycée à raison de 18h par an et
par classe soit une heure une heure
toutes les deux semaines ça fait débat
au sein de au sein des enseignants
est-ce que ce type de cours
voilà provoque des bas même entre
enseignants sur les valeurs qu'il faut
faire passer à travers ces fameux cours
d'éducation morale et civique alors ça
débat parce que je pense qu'on est tous
à peu près d'accord sur la finalité
l'objectif c'était c'est étendre de
développer leur sensibilité
à la démocratie au monde qui leur qui
les entoure
l'objectif c'est aussi de développer
leur sens critique face aux médias aux
communications le fait ça chaque prof
apporte sa pierre à l'édifice même si le
MC est plutôt dévolu au professeur
d'histoire-géo par contre on partage
tous oui pour tous quelque chose la
conscience politique et ce qu'elle
commence pour ces jeunes qui ont 13 14
ans dans une année comme on a vécu ici
en France par exemple ou bon c'est pas
comme je disais François Chevret ça
semble pas tout de même une probation
très importante dans leur tête je pense
qu'elle a commencé bien avant quand on
voit au début du documentaire sur
comment ils aspirent à demain sur la
lutte contre les inégalités la lutte
contre les discriminations les enjeux
sur l'écologie le réchauffement
climatique enfin tous ces enjeux là qui
sont des enjeux de société et qui sont
politiques ils parlent de politique
c'est pas forcément quand on va leur
demander et la politique c'est pas
forcément les réponses qui vont donner
mais sur leurs aspirations à la vie
demain ils ont un discours extrêmement
politique après les partis politiques
c'est pas forcément évident pas que pour
les plus adolescents pour les adultes
c'était pas forcément évident non plus
de s'en sortir mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que en gros les gros
candidats ils arrivaient avec
globalement à les situer à se rappeler
ça on voit bien que c'est des noms qui
leur évoquaient des choses et que les
moins médiatisé ou au moins grandes
heures d'écoute et ou de passage télé
vidéo et tout ça ben c'était plus
laborieux mais malgré tout ils ont un
propos ils envoient pas
François sur sur les roses en fait en
disant ça m'intéresse pas ça me concerne
pas ils se sentent concernés pas
forcément hyper légitime pour parler à
la télé de politique puisque la preuve
je crois que c'est Coline qui dit je
veux pas me tromper en vrai c'est pas
grave de se tromper sur où est-ce qu'on
met quelqu'un sur l'échiquier politique
voilà ce qu'il aurait été intéressant de
savoir mais qui est extrêmement
compliqué c'est qu'est-ce qu'elle a de
gauche qu'est-ce qu'elle a à droite pour
eux qu'est-ce qui mettait derrière
donc voilà mais je pense qu'ils ont y
compris dans leur pratique quotidienne y
compris dans leur débat entre eux quand
il y a le débat sur les classes prépa et
tout ça c'est pareil il parle de
politique sur ce des bas sur les classes
préparatoires déjà lorsqu'on a 13 ans
vous avez choisi de filmer et de mettre
dans votre film un cours de vie sexuelle
et affective d'ailleurs
le collège les Gayeulles est un bon
élève parce qu'il n'y a que 15%
seulement des établissements en France
aujourd'hui qui se plie à cette
obligation
qu'est-ce que vous en avez tiré de cette
séquence de ce tournage du ressenti des
élèves par rapport à l'enseignement
qu'il aurait fourni en matière
d'éducation sexuelle et affective
alors moi j'avais choisi de suivre ce
cours-là avec la classe de Coline et
Maëlle Coline n'a pas pu être là ce
jour-là donc j'ai eu comme à elle donc
je me suis concentré sur lui
bon voyez que ça l'intéressait qu'il
était attentif
après il était pas forcément prêt à
parler de ces choses là maintenant
c'est les discussions qu'on a eu après
c'est que à la fois il faut bien en
parler et à la fois c'était un peu tôt
pour lui c'est un peu ce que ce que j'ai
ressenti avec ses copains autour ils
étaient à peu près d'accord et surtout
en parler dans une classe avec avec une
prof et puis d'autres élèves qui sont
pas forcément des proches c'était pas
facile pour eux pas peine le tout
nouveau ministre de l'éducation
nationale
faisait ce même constat seulement 15%
des établissements se plie à cette
obligation de donner des cours et à
raison de trois séances par an seulement
pour par classe et il a eu ce mot la
conséquence de cette inaction collective
dit-il nous la connaissons tous
l'éducation sexuelle d'un nombre
croissant de jeunes se fait par le biais
d'Internet voir de la pornographie cela
ne fait qu'accentuer les comportements
virilistes déjà trop présents chez nos
élèves comportement qui nourrissent à la
fois les phénomènes de harcèlement et
les violences sexistes et sexuelle je
l'ai dit les gayeuls sont de bons élèves
en la matière ça vous paraît
indispensable de procurer ses cours
comme le prévoit d'ailleurs le programme
ça fait partie de tout ce qu'ils
représentent quand on les entend parler
c'est des gamins qu'on qui prennent tout
ce qui passe autour alors c'est un sujet
qui est compliqué à évoquer avec des
quatrième parce qu'ils sont encore ils
arrivent dans une phase où ils ont
beaucoup de questions sur eux-mêmes et
sur les autres ils changent
donc c'est compliqué d'aborder le sujet
avec eux mais
il aborde cependant avec des craintes et
a surtout avec beaucoup de curiosité
donc oui on a on est content ou Gaye
d'avoir des élèves qui sont
de la pétanque pour ça oui qui sont
réceptifs
il va y avoir une réforme du collège ils
sont plus utile le ministre actuel
semble vouloir augmenter ses heures de
cours de vie sexuelle et affective pour
les raisons que que j'ai indiqué
précédemment avec notamment ce qu'il a
dit dans cette interview de Love il y a
très peu de temps il y a quelques jours
c'était sous mois de novembre qu'en
pensez-vous par rapport aux jeunes qu'on
a vu là par exemple ce qui est
intéressant par exemple c'est quand ils
disent c'est gênant c'est gênant d'en
parler maintenant j'étais pas prêt mais
en fait ce qu'on voit bien dans le
projet de loi et dans la loi qui est
passée en 2000 dans les années 2000 au
début des années sur l'éducation la
sexualité c'est l'objectif voilà
l'objectif c'était un parcours en fait
de commencer dès le début de
l'instruction obligatoire et de
poursuivre jusqu'à la fin de
l'instruction obligatoire jusqu'à la fin
du lycée en gros et donc qui est pas le
moment où je suis pas prêt c'est pas le
bon moment puisque c'est progressif la
difficulté c'est que c'est pas forcément
mis en place dans tous les
établissements très peu en élémentaire
et du coup ça arrive souvent en classe
de 4e et troisième au moment où on n'est
pas forcément à l'aise pour en parler et
en même temps au moment où il y a
beaucoup de questions il va falloir
quand même entendre des choses et donc
c'est là où on voit et ils ont malgré
tout on voit bien ils sont très alertes
sur ce qui se dit dans la classe
ils ont la chance d'avoir ces séances
d'éducation la même si ils sont gênés
ils ratent pas une miette de
l'information et pour avoir pas mal
travaillé sur l'éducation la sexualité
en milieu scolaire on voit bien que ça
fait partie des attentes des jeunes et
que l'école le collège le lycée font
partie des institutions qui sont
reconnues comme étant légitime du point
de vue des ados pour donner de
l'information sur les relations
affectives la construction du corps la
construction de l'orientation sexuelle
de l'identité de genre et tout ça est-ce
qu'il y a déjà une auto-éducation de ses
enfants via notamment c'est vrai
décide pornographiques par exemple
est-ce que c'est le cas dans cette
génération husky il s'auto-éduc en la
matière et peut-être de la plus mauvaise
des manières en regardant justement
vraiment des sites pornographiques alors
dans une enquête qu'on a faite sur les
usages d'Internet en lien avec la
sexualité on voit qu'Internet en général
les mobilisé pour s'informer pour se
questionner pour découvrir des choses
sur la sexualité dans Internet il y a la
pornographie mais il n'y a pas
exclusivement que de la pornographie
donc parmi les ressources qu'il est
elles vont mobiliser il y a de la
pornographie mais parmi toute une
palette de ressources d'outils de
contenu en ligne hors ligne vidéo photo
il y a de plus en plus de ressources
pédagogiques aussi qui sont développées
par des influenceurs instagramurs
instagramus youtubeuses youtubeurs et
tout ça qui vont participer aussi à
produire un discours réflexif un
discours d'information un discours aussi
d'accompagnement à même d'être compris
entendu par ces jeunes parce qu'ils sont
formulés par peut-être des jeunes aussi
une génération qui est capable de leur
transmettre ces valeurs oui et puis par
des gens qui ont entendu les questions
qui se posent à longueur de journée
parce qu'en fait il y en a beaucoup qui
font aussi de l'intervention en milieu
scolaire et donc qui saisissent
qu'est-ce qu'on attend quand on est en
troisième où on en est aussi dans sa
sexualité et aujourd'hui en France
malgré ce qu'on a l'impression l'âge à
la première fois ne bouge pas on est
toujours autour de 17 ans pour les
filles et pour les garçons
dernière extrait du documentaire de
cette épisode épisode numéro 3 François
Chevret bah c'est la maman de Mohamed
qui s'intéresse et qui t'inquiète déjà
de l'avenir de son fils avec le fameux
stage de troisième qui va arriver
évidemment dans quelques mois regardez
mais voilà tu es encore
le stage
moi je veux bien faire au moins pour
essayer mais emballe pas tant que ça non
plus
moi ça m'inquiète parce que voilà il
faut
il faut trouver quelque chose pour le
stage je me fais une sélection c'est
doute est venu l'idée de faire de faire
pour moi un métier dans l'informatique
[Musique]
que elle fait tout pour pour l'aider lui
autre chose à penser en ce moment voilà
il est dans un âge où il a envie de
profiter de la vie et de profiter des
amis il aime le rap on a découvert et
puis surtout il adore ses amis en fait
et puis il adore rigoler en fait et
voilà donc
pour tout vous dire cette séquence là ça
a été très compliqué de la faire parce
que moi-même n'avait pas envie parce que
je pense qu'il en entend assez parler de
cette histoire-là il en avait pas envie
d'en parler donc on a réussi à faire
quelque chose mais voilà il aime pas ça
mais c'est aussi parce que sa mère est
inquiète c'est un peu une mère courage
cette femme qui qui donne beaucoup
beaucoup pour Mohamed
qui
elle n'a pas fait de grandes études qui
n'a pas un métier qui lui rapporte des
1000 et descents mais qui veut
absolument que son fils s'en sorte et le
plus simple c'est de trouver un métier
où il y a de l'emploi on entend aussi
Maël par exemple discuter avec certains
amis déjà de parcoursup alors là on a la
fin de la terminale
ce qui est une angoisse de la près
du cursus professionnel vers lequel il
pourrait aller par la suite déjà dans la
tête de ses enfants que vous suivez on a
parlé du cas de Mohamed
cette angoisse de l'après de la suite de
la vraie vie vous perçu déjà non non
pour le moment non ils sont pas encore
là et vous alors on a on a entre Maëlle
et Mohamed effectivement deux exemples
mais elle qui se tracent une route qui
sait où il va et Mohamed qui veut
surtout pas se tracer de route qui ira
sont deux élèves qui auront les moyens
de choisir un peu plus tard assez
facilement on le voit dans le reportage
et d'aller au lycée Chateaubriand le 1
qui est évidemment la référence qu'ils
ont tous en tête visiblement
Chateaubriand à Rennes où il y a des
d'ailleurs des classes préparatoires
voilà ensuite pour les études
supérieures il y a une angoisse tout de
même chez ces jeunes que vous percevez
sur l'avenir aujourd'hui leur avenir
peut-être professionnel ou c'est éternel
question qu'on leur pose qu'est-ce que
tu vas faire plus tard bon quand on a 13
ans alors l'angoisse on l'entend souvent
dans la dans la voie des parents
les élèves voilà il y a ceux qui ont qui
ont décidé de ce qui voulaient faire et
qui voilà ne sont plus angoissés il y a
ceux qui sont pas angoissés parce qu'ils
le savent pas et ça les préoccupe pas et
puis il y a une troisième catégorie qui
est faite la plus la plus délicate c'est
ceux qui qui sont en difficulté et qui
ne savent pas du coup qui ont des envies
et qui savent pas et c'est cela qui qui
va falloir vraiment guider et et
à qui va falloir apporter beaucoup
d'aide pour justement faire de bons
choix on leur demande de faire des choix
de plus en plus tôt maintenant
cette angoisse est-ce que c'est pas un
peu les parents qui transmettent ça à
leurs enfants peut-être à l'image
évidemment avec plein d'arrière bonne
arrière pensée pour pour un fils je
parle de la mère de moi-même par exemple
mais on va pouvoir d'une pression sur
les élèves aujourd'hui oui vous en
pensez on va voir aussi les effets des
classes sociales et des professions des
parents c'est à dire que Maëlle en fin
de prof et donc il va avoir une
socialisation aussi à l'univers scolaire
aux enjeux de l'orientation scolaire il
connaît déjà parcoursup mais du coup il
a déjà compris les enjeux derrière
parcoursup comment il faut se placer
pourquoi la prépa si tu veux rentrer en
prépa c'est maintenant qu'une partie des
choses vont se jouer et ainsi de suite
enfin il a un coût d'avance il joue aux
échecs mais il a un coup d'avance sur
beaucoup d'autres sur ben finalement
comment avoir les outils pour comprendre
ce qui se passe à l'école avec ses
multiples réformes il y a pas mal de
parents qui sont aussi perdus pour
accompagner leurs enfants et derrière un
peu le stress qu'on peut entendre sur
l'orientation il y a aussi être perdu
face à une institution qui se renouvelle
régulièrement
et puis on va voir de l'autre côté le
contre-exemple de Mohamed ou la maman
elle va chercher un métier pour son fils
un métier du coup voilà où il y a du
recrutement parce que l'objectif c'est
de trouver un travail mais on va le
retrouver aussi dans des propos alors je
crois que c'est Lilou qui dit moi dans
le monde plus tard je voudrais une école
qui forme des la sixième à des métiers
et en fait derrière on entend de
répondre à la question qu'est-ce que tu
veux faire plus tard quand on a 13 ans
c'est légitime de dire je veux changer
le monde sans savoir comment faire ou je
veux faire ma vie mais qu'on m'embête
pas pour ça et l'injonction des adultes
à dire et toi tu veux faire quoi c'est
extrêmement difficile mais extrêmement
normatif aussi et c'est s'exposer aux
violences liées au fait que on n'a pas
le niveau où d'autodisccrimination
d'auto limitation dans les aspirations
qu'on peut avoir quand on a 13 ans ce
sera le mot de la fin un grand merci à
tous les trois François Chevret vous
allez aller l'année prochaine on l'a
compris à à Manchester entre autres pour
continuer à suivre Coline puisque
choix de ses parents ils vont partir un
an sur place en Grande-Bretagne on verra
tout ça et on découvrira tout ça dans
l'épisode 4 de cette
série génération 2008 qui seront-ils
demain un grand merci à tous les deux
peut-être nous retrouverons-nous l'année
prochaine un pouvoir ce que sont aussi
devenus ces enfants vos réactions ça
sera sur hashtag des badoxes sur Twitter
bien entendu et je vous donne tout
simplement un prochain rendez-vous avec
un débat doc ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat très bientôt
[Musique]